Once you're in that grave, there's no I
could have, I would have, I should have.
Case closed. Allah tells us that a man
when he is soul is taken away, Allah
says he's going to say what? Send me
back to do Hajj, umrah, salah, fasting,
what? No sodak. Brothers and sisters,
aya is getting thousands of shahadas
monthly, yearly. Hundreds of thousands
of people are coming to Islam. They are
printing Quran, distributing material,
training duat. Brothers and sisters, do
you want a part of that goes on forever?
This is how Islam has spread around the
world, brothers and sisters. Carry on
this legacy of the prophetam inshallah
by donating whatever amount inshallah
and right now inshallah. Enjoy the
video. Asalamaikum
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah. This
is a specific uh special interview that
I'll be doing with Ustad Sharif from
political alchemy inshallah which uh
subhan allah I myself I'm subscribed to
guys and I urge you guys to subscribe to
get uh updates on the political uh
things that are going on around the
world brothers and sisters to be
updated. It is a uh kind of knowledge
that I do not per say have and
alhamdulillah to know that a Muslim
brother like brother Sharif is tackling
it going into details alhamdulillah and
giving you a perspective that you
haven't heard before. I urge you guys to
subscribe to his channel inshallah to be
up to date with the current affairs that
is going on. We have him here as well in
you can see on my left or my right
brothers and sisters and I am totally
clueless to this topic. I do not know
what is going on. So he is here to
educate me and educate you guys
inshallah brothers and sisters to what
is going on. I would be asking him
questions um and inshallah going into
details. How are you
for inviting me Ali?
>> It's a pleasure. Alhamdulillah. I've
been seeing your channel and I really
enjoy it. I love it. I love the the your
setup. I like the information how rich
and information it is. I love the fact
that it's coming from a brother like you
who's been in the DAO for years.
Alhamdulillah. And I love the B-rolls
and very engaging. Alhamdulillah. So
that's why I'm really urging and
encouraging people to subscribe to
political alchemy inshallah brother and
sisters. Um, may Allah bless and
preserve uh our brother inshallah um
Sharif. And when you do come to London,
we do want to invite you to our Salah
Pro studios. We've got a reason set up
here, alhamdulillah, to discuss this
stuff cuz I think me, myself, and the
viewers will be there's a lot to learn
from inah. So, u you know, it's called
the Dow Bros podcast. It's for all the
Dow Bros. It's not for anyone
specifically. So, we're looking forward
to come to London. Please, please be our
guest to come to the studio. But let's
get into something more serious in um
which is what's going on in Sudan. Um
I'll tell you firstly from my
perspective as a public figure and I'm
sure you're a public figure as well
yourself. Um people have been telling me
why you not talking about it? Why are
you not talking about it? Please talk
about it. And I don't know if you feel
like this and you can give me some
advice as well about you know from this
from a different perspective because
genuinely I'll be honest with you
sometimes you know I when jumping on
certain stuff it's it's sometimes I ask
myself a question Alli why are you doing
what you're doing? Yeah. And I really
get stuck sometimes where I'm like,
okay, am I jumping on this because I'm a
public figure and I have to talk about
it and which is there's truth to that
which I have to but sometimes I question
my sincerity. Why am I doing this or I'm
being encouraged to do it? Am I doing it
because people are telling me to do it
or of course we should all talk about
that's that's a given. But sometimes I
really am in this moral sincerity like I
really I don't know if it's from Shayan.
I don't know if it's Shayan making
making me overthink this more than it is
but I genuinely sometimes you know these
things become fashion you know I see
people I'm not trying to blame anyone
I'm not saying it's blame worthy like
people um making dua for them with a
camera on etc like and I accept it like
I I believe it's it's a very honorable
thing to do I just feel like sometimes I
don't know I don't know I'm a bit lost
for words but what I'm just saying this
in a nutshell is that when things like
this happen people jump on it becomes
like a fashion it becomes like a trend
And I feel like it's sometimes it's sad
because this human life that's been
lost, you know, and sometimes I don't
know if you have that. Yeah.
>> But I've been feeling a bit like that.
Like and and what advice would you give
me? Because I get stuck. I'm like,
>> should I do a video or should I hate it
in my heart and be like make daggin
sincerely? Do I have to say it on
camera? Do you get do you get what I'm
trying to say?
>> No. No. I understand what you're saying
100%. And I think what it is is that the
fear is is that you're jumping on the
bandwagon. Yes. because you're trying to
get clicks and likes and people to watch
the video because everybody's talking
about it and you feel the need
>> but I think Ali like you mentioned you
are a public figure you have
alhamdulillah a very big uh subscriber
base and uh social media footprint and
it's important that we learn and we
explain about these topics to Muslims
because otherwise if we're not
explaining it unfortunately what tends
to happen is then you get non-Muslims
that then try to present the false
picture of what's actually occurring. So
for instance, there are many people out
there, many Christians, many, you know,
far-right individuals that try to give
this as though this is a civil war, this
is a genocide against Christians in
Darur uh or in Sudan, which is
completely false. And this has been done
by, you know, quote unquote, Islamists
or people who are Islamic and that's
completely far from the truth. And
unfortunately if we don't challenge
these stereotypes, we don't challenge
these misconceptions, these lies, these
propaganda, then unfortunately they
start to stick in the minds of a lot of
people. And and I think you know you're
right to a certain extent which is that
we can't be experts in everything. So
that's where you know inshallah whether
it's myself or other brothers we try to
go out to those people that we know who
are experts who may understand the top
topic area you know better that we go to
them and we ask them questions and
that's what I've certainly been doing
regardless of what the current situation
of Sudan is. Yeah, same. I mean, Allah
says in the Quran, if you don't know,
ask somebody that knows that's the
reason I've come to you. I mean, let's
get straight into it. That was a
beautiful reminder because some shayan
comes to us, you know, we do want to do
the right thing in the right way, you
know, and I guess you're right. It is a
responsibility upon me to talk about it
cuz I do have a platform. So, yeah,
maybe it's from Shayan, but I just
genuinely want to sincerely do this, you
know, and I ask Allahh that all of us,
all of us in the public sphere that we
do this for the right reasons,
inshallah, and Allah accepts it from us
that it's not something that's a trend
or a fashion or for the clicks or the
views. So getting straight into it, what
is going on in Sudan? Where is this
started from? Like if I'm not mistaken,
this has been going on for quite a good
couple of years.
>> That's right. So is it look whenever we
talk about civil war of any country is
always complex. There's going to be
various complex factors that have
resulted in you know population of the
same country starting to fight each
other. Now when it comes to the issue of
the current civil war in Sudan, it
started uh in the current situation in
April 2023. So it was between two
groups. One's called SAF or the Sudin
armed forces and the other group is
called the RSF also known as the rapid
support forces. The one who led the SAF
or the Sudin armed forces is a person
called Abdul Fata al- Burhan. And the
one who leads the RSF is somebody who's
popularly known as Hmedi. Yeah. or
Muhammad Hamdan Dalo. So these are two
individuals. Now what's interesting is
that both of them were actually part of
the leadership and the government of
Sudan. So Abdul Fatal Burhan he was the
the leader of Sudan uh in an interim
military government and Amedi he was
vice president or vice leader of the
country.
>> And so I think really the question is
why why did they fight each other?
What's what's this war really about? And
like I said, there's a lot of complex
factors that requires a bit of knowledge
about history and about what's going on.
But fundamentally, we need to look at
maybe or very briefly, we need to look
at 2019.
>> So in Sudan in 2019, there was popular
uprisings, popular protests, not
violent, they were peaceful protests
that took place across Sudan in which
they called for the removal of Omar
al-Bashir, who is the leader of Sudan.
and he'd been the leader since 1989. And
these protesters didn't just demand the
removal of Omar al- Bashir who was seen
as this autocratic oppressive ruler but
also the military regime that he
represented. So they were trying to call
for the end of the military regime
>> and so after the protest Omar al- Bashir
was removed and then an interim process
took place where they had military
leaders people like Abdul Fata al- Bhan
and also civilian rulers or civilian
politicians and they came together in
2019 2020 and then in 2021 so about a
year or 18 months later there was meant
to be a full transition of power. So
there was meant to be transition from
this interim military civilian
government to a fully civilian
government. Then what happened is that
Abdul Fatal Borhan the head of the Sudin
armed forces then did a coup against the
civilian government or the civilian part
of the interim government and he removed
uh the prime minister and all the
civilian politicians from power and took
complete leadership and that's when he
became the leader and Jamei the head of
the RSF became his vice leader and then
after about another year or 18 months
they said they'll have a fully
transitional government to a civilian
government And that was meant to take
place in April 2023,
the same month that suddenly this
fighting took place, which then delayed
and has therefore been delaying this
transitional government to a uh civilian
government ever since. So that's that's
just a very brief background. There's
even more details regards to this.
>> Interesting. So they uh were uh joint
forces.
>> They were joint in the beginning. In the
beginning
>> that's right.
>> Okay. So what went wrong?
>> So okay. So maybe his question is who is
the RSF and who is the Sunnis armed
forces and what's their relationship? So
like I said Omar Bashir when he was
leader from 1989 to 2019 he was
basically effectively the face or the
ruler of this military regime and and
unfortunately many of our countries have
military regimes like Egypt is another
example of this.
So when the protest took place they were
calling for the removal of Omar Bashir
and the military regime. Now Omar Bashir
what he did is that he used pe like the
SAF the Sudin armed forces and also the
RSF as people that would support his
military rule. Now they betrayed him and
did the coup against him. Now the real
question is who is the RSF? Because the
RSF, if you remember, I don't know Ali
if you remember uh the Janjuid in the
early 2000s and
>> no during that period and the Darur
crisis that took place.
>> I've heard of the name Janji but I don't
know what what it's about. So in the
early 2000s there was basically
rebellion that took place in Darur and
there's a whole background as to why
this rebellion took place and a lot of
it comes down to the British colonial
rule because Britain colonized Sudan and
ruled over the country and they created
a system where they favored certain
tribes in Darur over other tribes and
excluded a lot of the Arab uh or the you
ethnically Arab tribes within the Darur
region and this created a lot you know
uh tribalism and uh you know tensions
amongst these various groups and so
there and in addition to that there was
a lot of gold mines and Omar Basher who
was the head of the government basically
didn't distribute the wealth and so
therefore a large proportion of these
people were in poverty so you've got a
lot of poverty you've got the military
rule which is trying to you know usurp
all the wealth and also at the same time
you've got this tensions this tribal
tensions that's taking place so
rebellion started taking place. So what
Omar Basher did is that he gathered
certain tribes name mainly the the
ethnically Arab tribes and by the way
these are not Islamic these people were
not Islamic whatsoever. In fact if you
go to the Wikipedia article about the
RSF they call themselves anti-Islamists.
Yeah these are jail people. Yeah these
are Jhill people. Yeah and we can see
what they did. So throughout the 2000
they were supported by Omar Bashir to
put down these rebellions and they would
go to villages after villages raise the
village kill the men and unfortunately
dishonor the women and these by the way
these are Muslims. Yeah. So the people
the African Dorian tribes that they were
doing this against the people who
rebelled against Basher they were
Muslims they weren't non-Muslims they
weren't Christians they were Muslims.
Yeah. And so they were going around
dishonoring. And the word, by the way,
Ali, the word Janjuided, it comes from
two words and it means jin on horseback.
>> So these Janjueds basically were calling
themselves devils on horseback.
>> This is this is the RSF, right?
>> This is so later the Janjuid then got
incorporated by Omar Bashir and were
called the RSF.
>> So the other
party was called what they are called?
Sudin armed forces.
>> So are they are they like Muslims in
Well, I know they're both Muslims, but
are they um not as
>> Yeah. So they're Muslims. So Sudanese
armed forces, you know, generally
Muslims and but unfortunately
>> they benefited by continuing the
military rule because the military would
then monopolize on a lot of the wealth,
a lot of the gold resources, uh the
limited amount of oil resources that
they had. They had a lot of oil
resources. But when the south of Sudan,
which is now a Christ, which was a uh
majority Christian area, when they
rebelled basically and they were
supported by America and other western
states, then they basically created
their own country. Now that country is
called the South Sudan. So you got Sudan
which is one country and South Sudan as
another country and that only was
created in 2011. So this is the case.
So, so basically Sudan, the Sudan and
South South Sudan are Christians.
>> South Sudan is now like Christian
majority country. Yeah. So, Sudan,
>> the war is happening there or not
happening there?
>> No. No. That's now completely out of it.
They're no longer involved. They have
their own problems. Yeah.
>> Okay. Perfect. So, this firstly dispels
because if if the issue is Sudan, which
they the far right is trying to use
against Christians or whatever it is for
that matter that they're calling, they
would have attacked South Sudan, right?
>> That's right. That's right. So, so it's
going to have to do with Christian
Muslim.
>> Yeah.
>> There are some Christians in in in
regular Sudan now that we seize today,
but there are like a couple of percent 2
3% maybe. Uh they're not that many in
Sudan. And that area of Darur is
predominantly Islamic. And I'll show you
a map regards to that so that you can
show to the audience the demographics,
the religious demographics of the areas.
And you can see very clearly from the
map that the area of Dur the area of
Katum and Sudan they're predominantly
Muslim.
>> Yeah. While you're doing that, I want to
share a video with I want to quickly
just go to one video just to react to
it. Uh
one second,
one second. Let me just show you. I want
you to watch. This is a a a woman um in
a hijab RSF forces or whatever like
literally um commanding to the the the
rape rape of um woman. Um let me just
send it to you. Yeah, there she is. I
want you to just watch this with me in
I'm just going to send it to you on your
WhatsApp and just quickly watch this.
Let's let's just quickly react to this
inshallah. Yeah, give me one second.
Allahb.
Okay. So here you have a woman in hijab
who was saying go there and cleanse
their lineage which is basically talking
about raping women and other Muslim. So
you what you said about the RSF they are
they sound like these satans on horses
with all due respect or gins whatever
you want to call them. Um how does this
make you feel like looking at this
seeing a Muslim woman in hijab
commanding I don't know what her duty
is. I don't know if she's a commander. I
don't know what she's for that matter
commanding um subhan Allah the rape of
other Muslim women.
>> I know it's absolutely disgusting. And
this is the problem of tribalism. This
is a problem of the lack of Islam. This
is ignorance and jahalyah. Yeah.
Complete absolutely utter jahalia. And
you know it's it's very hard for us to
understand how Muslims can act this way.
But I think what we have to realize is
that
>> you know these people are completely you
know away from Islam and the actions are
completely you know utterly
reprehensible something that you know we
all condemn absolutely and utterly um
you know and so you know this is it's
very clear
>> uh regards to the complete you know
disgusting nature and unfortunately this
is
>> this is the reality of unfortunately of
how the governments of our lands have
and using these types of individuals and
these types of groups and militias to
create this type of chaos within the
Muslim world.
>> So yeah, subhan Allah. It's really
really sad. Um, you said the British
once again has its hands in
you know this chaos and unrest and you
did say that there were South Sudan
there's Christians what they 3% uh
population free.
>> So is the Christian population of South
Sudan obviously they're the majority in
that new country called South Sudan. Uh
and obviously like I said the the
British themselves they've they've had
the role. See when the British came they
colonized Sudan. So it was in the late
19th century early 20th century. Sudan
only got its independence in 1956 from
the British who were effectively the
rulers of that country. It was like a uh
so they were effectively rulers but what
they did in place like Darur Darur used
to have like a system where the under
the Darur sultenate they before the
British they would allocate lands to
various tribes but it wasn't a permanent
allocation but rather it was simply a
way to decentralize the collection of
taxes and administer you know any
disputes etc. But what the British did
is they created something called native
administration where they gifted lands
to loyal tribes or loyal clans that were
loyal to the British and because of that
they created a system where they created
tribalism and tension amongst the
various tribes and that lasted for
generations. And so what we're now
seeing is some of the fruits of that in
the same way we saw the fruits of of
South Sudan breaking away because what
the British did because the British
allowed Christian missionaries to go
into South Sudan to convert like the the
local population who weren't Muslim.
They were following various local
African religions. They allowed them to
go into South Sudan, convert the uh
convert them into a Christian
population, but also prevented Muslims
from going and spreading the Islamic Dow
in this region. So this is when the
British were in charge because they
wanted to create a loyal population of
Christian Sudin that therefore they
could use to secure their interest that
would be more loyal to them than to the
wider majority Muslim population of
Sudan.
>> Interesting. So can I So we've made it
clear. So the way the reason why these
people are so ruthless like you know the
other parties so you got the the Sudan
defense was it Sudin
>> Sudin armed forces. Yeah
>> Sudin armed forces. Yeah. So are they
moving cuz all I'm seeing is the RSF are
committing all these atrocities and this
is this ethnic cleansing. I think we can
even call it genocide if I'm not
mistaken.
>> Yeah that's right. Yeah.
>> Yes. It's I mean that's what it is. And
we are alhamdulillah morally consistent
in this matter and we are you know we're
not we're not you know we don't um you
know just we're not strategically
consistent. We're morally consistent as
Muslims. Yeah. And the west has exposed
itself with the whole Zionism and what's
going on and I would be surprised if
Zionist have a hand in this as well. So
with the um Sudanese armed forces have
they been doing committing atrocities
like this or are they like cuz I don't
know what's going on. Is this only
happening from the RSF? And if so what's
what differentiates them because they're
both tribal. is one following the
correct way of Islam and the other one's
warped idea of tribalism. What? So yeah.
>> Yeah. So like say it's a complex
situation because when the Janjuid were
being used by Omar Bashir who was the
ruler and he was the therefore he was
the ruler of the SAF. They're not a
tribe. They're like the Sudanese armed
forces. Yeah.
>> And he would also be the ruler over the
Janjuided and he was directing them or
the RSF as they later became known. Then
he was using both the RSF or the
Janjuided with the Sudin armed forces.
So both of them were committing
atrocities. They were supporting the
atrocities that were taking place. Now
the reason why he needed the Janjuided
or the RSF is because they were also
busy with the civil war that was taking
place in South Sudan. And so therefore
they needed uh like a local militia and
this is how they used the Janu or the
RSF. you know, Abdul Fatal Burhan, who's
now the head of the Sudin armed forces,
was actually a commander of the Sudin
armed forces in Darur and worked with
the RSF. So while the RSF was doing
this, this is before April 23rd I'm
talking about. So before the 2019
protests that took place before that, he
was a commander of the armed forces in
Darur. So it's very hard to
differentiate between the the the crimes
that the RSF did with the crimes of Omar
Bashir who was in power and also the
crimes of the Sudin armed forces. Now at
the moment you know the reality is is
that the only people that are likely to
protect the Muslims in the whole region
are the Sudin armed forces. But this is
where the problem gets you know even
more complex because there are a lot of
outside powers that are influencing and
prolonging the civil war. So as an
example of this this city aler which is
the main city of darur and it's the
reason why this has become in the media
recently in the last week or so is
because it got taken by the RSF for 500
days. It withstood many of the local
rebel militias joined with the SAF
joined with SAF Sudin armed forces and
fought against the RSF and they actually
prevented them from entering the
country. the RS. But what happened was
that there was a conference between four
countries, America, Sudan, Egypt, and
the UAE. And then two days later after
this conference, the Sudin armed forces
withdrew its troops from defending al
Farer. This is something that even Abdul
Fat al- Bhan, the head of the armed
forces of Sudin armed forces, he admits
to. He said that yeah, we did this
because in his words, we thought we were
going to protect the civilians by
removing them. But what happened? It
left the city defenseless. And as a
result, the RSF came in, murdered and
killed many of the men, forced them to
dig their own graves, and then crawled
into these graves while they were being
buried. Yeah.
And then raped unfortunately or, you
know, um, assaulted
the women on mass, you know. So it's
quite
>> disgusting. So these people seems like
the armed forces. Sorry.
>> There is no Islamic like I'm looking at
this and I'm thinking you know I mean
only the far right and these maniacs
would agree on what they're doing. They
both would. I mean I think one thing in
common will be like your likes of you
know Tommy Robinson and his cronies like
Liam Tuff and whoever they are. The only
two people that would agree that what
they're doing is Islamic is both the RSF
and the far right. They will say yeah
this is Islamic. No, even the RSF don't.
You see, the RSF don't justify what
they're doing as Islamic. They're not
like, you know, some of these other
quote unquote groups who try to justify
it based upon so
they don't not that they don't believe
in Islam. They don't believe that they
need to justify this in any way from any
scripture or text.
>> So, they're just doing it basically.
They're basically saying, "We're just
doing it."
>> Yeah. Yeah. Remember, like I said, they
consider themselves quote unquote
anti-Islamist religions.
>> Yeah. Wow. Wow. Subhan Allah. Subhan
Allah.
>> So I think the problem is is regards to
this situation is that the SAF are the
only group that could manage to defeat
this RSF. But unfortunately the type of
leadership are the leadership that was
actually working with the RSF before
this rebellion or this civil war took
place. And so that's why it's a very
complex picture and like I said because
you've now got outside powers
unfortunately supporting the two
different factions particularly you know
and I know it's a bit controversial but
particularly the UAE sadly who are
supplying weapons and arms to the RSF
something which the United Nations
leaked document has exposed something
that is you know weapons that have been
taken by the SAF have the names of Abu
Dhabi of UAE.
>> Wow. I was going to ask you armored
vehicles or the ark. Yeah. What's the
evidence?
>> Yeah. I was going to ask you what are
the evidences like because people saying
it's allegations. Some people saying
that the planes were landing because of
the gold trade or something like that.
So you're actually saying the UN has um
come out and said this is actually the
case.
>> Yeah. It's it's now become open. And
look, the UAE used they actually paid
for services of the RSF to go and fight
under their banner, the UAE banner in
Yemen. So there is a very strong
relationship between the UAE and the
RSF. This this you know devils on
horseback. Yeah. the shin. So there's a
very close relationship between them and
also people are saying that the reason
why UA are doing this is because it's
helps you know with the gold and gold
mines because all the gold mines are
predominantly within Darur region uh as
well as securing agricultural crops and
food security as they say but
unfortunately UAE have been acting in a
way where anytime there's a popular
protest anytime there's something which
is perceived as potentially going
towards an Islamic type of governance
they've stepped stepped in to be what
they call counterrevolutionaries,
meaning they're trying to stop people
from calling for revolution or calling
for a a change. And remember in this all
started in the recent in 2019 when there
were popular protests when Muslims of
Sudan, you know, throughout the region,
throughout the country were calling for
the end of military rule and the
implementation of, you know,
civilian-based government. Now they
weren't telling you what type of
civilian based government but Sudan
believe it or not apart from these
certain individuals and militias is a
highly Islamic or highly you know you
know they hold on to Islam strongly. So
any type of civilian government is
always going to be rooted in Islamic
sentiment. That's what you know that's
and that is a concern for people who are
concerned about popular revolutions
where Islamic governance comes in and
that potentially could spread throughout
the region as we saw in 2010 during the
Arab Spring when there was uh protests
and revolutions that took place in
Tunisia. Within weeks it spread to
Egypt, to Libya, to Syria, you know, to
even there was protests in Algeria, to
Yemen, you know, even in Bahrain as
well, you know. So there was so
therefore UAE and other some of these
countries are concerned about a second
form of popular uprisings.
>> I don't know how much detail you want to
go into it but there's leaked cable
reports you know Wikileaks which leaked
out these American cables these secret
discussions that took place with
leaders. One of them was Muhammad bin
Zed who's now the current leader of UAE
who actually said that you know the
Middle East is not like California. You
can't just simply hold elections and
free and fair elections because they'll
vote in the Islamists. There's leak
cables the way he said that and he said
that in 2007 so even before the Arab
Spring. So there's been an agenda in
terms of trying to support uh some of
the what they quote unquote the
secularists uh within these regions and
maintain the status quo which is
military rule within these regions as
well.
>> Interesting. But you know just one thing
Sach maybe a little bit off topic but um
you know rebellion don't you feel like
rebellion what's happening isn't it
causing more harm because we're seeing
now what's going in Sudan. Yeah. And I
know maybe your stance might be a bit
different to this but like do you not
think this the reason why rebellion it's
I mean it's it's so dangerous because
the thing is now look how the country is
now like what was before and he might be
ruling under somebody who may have not
been like you know up to notch or
whatever it is but don't you think the
harm is greater now because we have been
told like I know some there is the
extreme where people take this out of
context where you know you cannot rebel
in any way shape or form or uh you know
but do you not think it brings more harm
So yeah, so what we have to understand
is that in 2019 they weren't re
rebelling per se. They were protesting
and there were peaceful protests that
took place. And remember also this is a
period where the Omar Bashir was sending
in the Janjuid. So prior to this he was
sending in the Janjuid to basically wipe
out villages. So I'm not talking about
now 2023. I'm talking about in the
2000s. So even before you know all of
these protests that took place in 2019
these types of actions were being taken
place. So we have this situation where
unfortunately
we have leadership which doesn't
represent what the sentiments are of the
Muslims and the um people protest
peacefully and they're shot at and
killed.
>> And the question is well what do you do?
you just perpetuate the systemic
oppression and abuse that's taking place
or do you try to speak out against it?
And as Muslims and remember also by the
way um
>> when the Abraham Accords came in this
normalization process,
>> we talk about UAE and we talk about
other countries, but Sudan was one of
the people that signed the normalization
with Israel as well. And so really in
>> South Sudan or Sudan.
>> What's that?
>> South Sudan or Sudan?
>> Sudan. Sudan. Not South Sudan. Sudan.
>> Sudan. So Sudan signed a normalization
deal with Israel.
>> That's right.
>> So one second. Which which which RSF or
the uh the Sudan army armed forces.
>> So this is when you had the interim
government with the RSF, with the SAF
and with civilian uh uh leadership as
well with this interim government that
took place. So that that so that
government before they did the the
coupube that government was trying to
normalize relation with um Israel.
>> Yeah. And remember although the prime
minister was somebody called Abdullah
Hamduck and he was part of quote unquote
the civilian coalition the chairman so
the guy who sits above him was Abdul Fat
al- Borhan the head of the Sud Sudin
armed forces. He was the chairman and he
was the one that enacted the coup. So
it's that's why I'm saying it's a very
complicated situation and it's a
situation unfortunately with regards to
what's happened there and the other
countries unfort that have been fueling
the the civil war is very sad and at the
head of all of that is then America
because something that is widely
wellknown something that even Omar
Basher who is a leader previous leader
before the coup even he mentioned that
America's plan was to separate Sudan
into five different parts. South Sudan
became one part and Darur was going to
be another part. And now if you again if
you look at this map, I'll show you the
map. If you look at the map, you will
see that the RSF control pretty much the
whole of Darur and the SAF which is
basically the Sudin government. They're
meant to be the official government and
the people officially in charge. They
control the north and the east. Yeah. So
it's basically split the country in two.
>> And the reason why is because Sudan
prior to 2011 was rich in oil, was rich
in gas, was rich in gold, had massive
amounts of agricultural and fertile
lands, places like Darur and also gold
and it had its own deep sea port, Port
Sudan. So it's a it's a rich country.
It's a you know resource rich country.
It was the biggest country in the whole
of Africa as well before South Sudan,
you know, split from Sudan. So, it's not
a uh it wasn't a weak per se. Even
though people look at Sudan as being
poor, it's just been poorly managed. And
this is the problem that we have is that
yeah, we're not calling for rebellion
and we're not calling for violent
overthrow. And to be honest, Muslims
didn't call for violent when when April
2023 took place. This wasn't a violent
overthrow because sincere Muslims or
Muslims misguided and sincere tried to
overthrow the government. It was the
vice president and the president or the
leader and the vice leader who went to
war with each other. Not the ordinary
Sudin. Sudinis have never supported this
this civil war but rather they
themselves who are colleagues who
apparently you know worked together and
were friends. They took their forces and
started fighting each other. So, subhan
Allah, once again, the Zionist hands are
in this because to me, I'm so
bamboozled. Like, Sudan was trying to
normalize relations with Israel. So, to
me, this this shows me like I mean, I
don't know what kind of Islam is in
there. It shows me there is I mean
trying to normalize relation with
Israel. So, to me, it seems like a an
effort that's going on. And number one,
I think they're using this also to take
the attention away from the genocide
that's happened in Gaza. It has to be
strategically. Yes, this was I think
this what happening after, you know, the
damage that's been caused by the uh
public opinion. Um, you know, what's
happening on the ground against the
resistance. Um, you know, they're losing
this battle on all grounds. You know,
the public opinion changing in America.
Um, you know, people are waking up and I
think this is another strategic move to
divert attention. And not only that, for
them to to see that the Sudanese
government were trying to normalize
relation with Israel, that that tells me
a lot of what's literally going on
there, you know, this is so messy. It is
messy. It's a very messy situation. Like
I said, whenever country goes to war
with itself, there's always going to be
mess and there's always going to be
different competing interests that's
taking place. And what doesn't help is
outside forces that do this. And
obviously the the whole project of
Israel and the greatest you know the
greater state of Israel all that type of
thing greater Israel part of its project
is to weaken any potential rival
countries within the region whether
that's you know uh Egypt or Sudan or any
other country Syria as we seeing today
is to weaken them so that they are the
only dominant power within that region
and it's also the same position regards
to the west and America and Britain
Britain prior but America now which is
to weaken the Muslim world to divide it
to create these you know um tribalistic
nationalistic lines that can't heal the
hearts and I think this is maybe where
we can look at you know we had similar
situation during the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in where the
banaz fought wars with each other and it
was only Islam that they actually
realized actually Islam is the unifying
factor is this bond that can bring them
together
>> yeah and that's what they fear the most
I Islam is a sleeping giant and they
genuinely fear it. They genuinely fear
it and they do not want uh the you know
the to come back that's something that
they clearly do it and they're doing it
through God knows so many other means
and you got and spies and god knows
what. Subhan Allah. I mean so where do
you see the direction going now? You
know just like kind of maybe slowly
wrapping up or if there's anything else
you want to say. Where do you think the
direction is going? What can we do?
Obviously there's humanitarian aid and
etc. whatever whatever else we can do.
But where do you think the direction is
going? Where do you think this is going
to finish? Because this is horrific.
Like the stuff that I'm seeing genuinely
like it's affecting my mental health and
this might sound selfish, but I cannot
watch it. I I genuinely cannot watch it
because
it's it's very very disturbing. So where
do you think this is heading towards and
what can we do as Muslims to protect our
you know Sudanese brothers and sisters
be their Christian, Muslim, whatever
faith they are? It's horrific.
Look, there's no easy solution
unfortunately and there's only limited
things that we can talk about and try to
do uh from ourselves here. But I think
unfortunately where it's leading towards
is a split in the country. It's going to
there's probably going to be potentially
negotiations, a ceasefire and a split
where the RSF controls Darur region and
then the SAF will control and then you
have split within Sudan. That's
unfortunately is a sad situation. What
we can do I think I know again it sounds
controversial but what we need to do
honestly and sincerely we need to expose
the external actors in this the external
countries that are funding yeah and that
are supporting
you know the the type of chaos that's
taking place and that means to a certain
extent we have to expose the UAE because
the UAE are not just doing this in Sudan
they did this with Muhammad Morsi in
Egypt where They pro they actually
funded and supported protest and then
funded and supported Cece when he came
to power and got rid of Muhammad Morsi.
We talk about rebellion being haram.
Yeah. Well, that was a rebellion against
an elected leader and yet they rebelled
against him. And not only that, but then
they executed him, you know, under
trumped up charges. And when the west
sanctioned s uh Egypt, UAE and Saudi,
unfortunately, both of them bankrolled
Cece's government to allow them to
remain in power. They were doing this in
Yemen where they've set up, you know,
death squads, American mercenaries.
They've actually hired American
mercenaries and also they used the RSF
to go into Yemen. They're doing this
with General Hafta of Libya where
they've support him against what they
call Islamist groups and Islamist
organizations. And in this country and
in the West, they've been sadly funding
Islamophobic narratives against the
Muslims here, calling for the banning
of, you know, Islamic relief.
>> That's considered a terrorist
organization in the UAE, and they call
for their banning. In America, you have
care and they've called for their
banning as well, you know, and their
care was the organization that brought
Sami Hamdi recently to do a speaking
tour and he's in prison.
>> Yeah, I was going to talk about that as
well. Subhan Allah. Like I'm supposed to
do a video about that as well.
>> Um Yeah, he's Subhan Allah. What's going
on? Is he being released?
>> Unfortunately, he's probably going to be
there for another week or so. Uh he's in
detention, but he's challenging that
detention from what I understand,
inshallah. And uh
>> what's the reason for this?
>> So you know obviously we pray to
Allahhana tala but
>> I mean what's saying this is that the
RSF and the civil war in Sudan would
have been over quite in a short period
of time if there weren't outside funders
and backers and unfortunately it's
because of the outside forces that are
backed that prolonged this civil war and
allowed the RSF militia to have the arms
and the weapons to undertake the
massacres that they have. So it's a
difficult decision and I understand it
can be seemed controversial but reality
is is that we have to expose some of
these organizations some of these
countries that are promoting this and
become aware of what's going on and then
obviously from our perspective we have
to make dua to Allah subhana wa tala as
best as we possibly can as sincerely as
possibly can for the people of Sudan
that Allahhanaa heals their hearts and
removes this civil war and the the
devils that are you know engaged in the
massacres that have taken place there.
>> So, you know, that's what I would say is
learn about the situation, understand
what's going on in the world today
because if we don't understand what's
going on in the world today, then we're
just going to get played. Yeah. We're
just going to get, you know, one crisis
after another crisis. And, you know,
Alli, one of the biggest factors that
weakens or creates doubts that I've come
across amongst Muslims,
>> Yeah.
>> isn't necessarily some of the
theological arguments. It's because when
they look at the Muslim world, they say,
"If Islam is so true, then why is the
Muslim world in such chaos?"
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. And so if you don't understand
what's going on that it's not actually
the Muslims or Islam that's the problem
here.
>> Yeah.
>> It's not Islam. It's actually the lack
of Islam.
>> Yeah. Lack of Islam. Not only that,
you've got Zidist, the one the the
greatest I'm so sorry. They're the
greatest mischief makers who have their
hands everywhere. You know, USS Liberty,
you know, you could call it conspiracy.
You can call it wherever you like. You
know, JFK, you know, disappears 911.
I'll be honest with you, call it the the
Americans are waking up to this. They
have their hands everywhere. I mean, but
so much so I would even say Charlie
Kirk. I mean, I found it so shocking
when someone told me that Benjamin
Netanyahu, the Satan, he actually went
on TV and had to say, "Oh, we didn't
kill Charlie Kirk." And I was like,
"Wow, the fact that first time in
history that you have to go to a TV
station, be invited, by the way, it's
all set up." And the woman says, "Not
that we believe in it, but they're
saying that you was involved." And for
him to say, "Oh, to even reply and
entertain that shows how the public
opinion has swifted so shockingly that
Benjamin Netanyahu has to come on TV and
say, "We didn't kill him, by the way."
Yeah. And and and Candace Owens is doing
a fantastic job exposing. And this is
what it is. You you claim Islam is the
issue of Muslims. With all due respect,
Islam ruled the half of the earth. Yes.
For centuries. and the Muslims and
Christians live side by side side in
peace. Yes. So to to to say that Islam
is the problem, it's not. It's those
outside sources, forces um and the the
the them invading countries for their
resources, for their political gains or
whatever is what's causing the um
instability, you know, and and I think
that's clear. I think people are not
buying it anymore. You know, this thing
of Islam and this the West has genuinely
woken up to this reality.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
100% I agree with you in terms of that
that people are waking up
>> in terms of the fact that western
interference
>> and you know uh people with ulterior
motives are interfering within the
Muslim world and like I said the seeds
of the tribalism and the tension that
created issues with regards to South
Sudan or Darur originally comes from the
British colonial rule when they
colonized this area and it's been
perpetuated by a military dictatorship
that sadly hasn't really made Islam the
source. Now obviously Sudan and Omar
Bashir claimed that he wanted to
implement Islam but on the practical
rulings of Islam apart from a few rules
like some of the hadud rules he didn't
implement Islam in that in that sense.
So Islam is not to blame. Unfortunately
we're still suffering from this postc
colonial
>> you know hangup that we've had.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Inferiority complex. Yeah.
So you're going to be doing a video
about this if I'm not mistaken. You're
going to go into
>> That's right. in.
>> Okay. So, any last words? And guys, you
can in check out political alchemy
inshallah. It's a YouTube channel where
brother Sharif goes into details about
these issues. You can keep up to date.
It's very enlightening to know what's
going on. I've learned a lot today. Any
last words, bro, uh for the viewers and
any advice for them what they can do?
>> Yeah. So, like I said, make dua to
Allahhana wa tala that Allahhana tala
helps the people of Sudan. Uh you know,
where we can in terms of charity, we
need to give charity, but also just to
understand what's going on is an action
in itself. And and therefore with that
when you understand what's going on you
can counteract the lies especially from
the pro-Zionist shills who try to say
that this is you know Muslims and
Islamists and people who want Sharia
attacking and killing and genociding and
acting according to their faith. And we
know exactly it's the complete opposite
of that that's occurring. It's not
against Christians. Christian Christian
is nothing to do with Christians. This
is not a Christian genocide. This is
against Muslims themselves. And
unfortunately it's forces that have been
supported by outside forces that have
been created you know that the the
tensions and the issues have been
created from outside forces from western
interference that created the
environment for this to take place. So
that's my final words inshallah upon
that. Thank you. May Allah bless you
inshallah brother and sisters subscribe
to the uh political alchemy channel
inshah brother and sisters to keep up to
date uh brother shar inshah till next
time and if you do ever come to London
do let us know brothers and sisters um
sorry I mean brother shar do let me know
when you come down inshallah and we can
invite you to our studio and yeah guys
till next time inshallah do not forget
to make keep the brothers and sisters in
Sudan innocent people in your duas
giving charity as much as you can
inshallah hopefully the aid will reach
them and may Allahh deal with oppressors
and expose them those who are causing
fitna um you know disorder in the land.
Subhan Allah.